you are watching a clip from the john
perry channel
genetics and evolution
more on the skull size that accommodates
the brain have you seen or heard of
these cases of hydrocephaly where the
skull gets huge
their skull will be maybe like twice as
the size of a normal skull
because they're getting they call it
water in the brain it's just you're
making too much spinal fluid that does
suggest that the skull is growing based
on pressure within it as opposed to some
sort of a pre-programmed
size that the bone is going to grow
so yes i know most of these kids like
unless they're yeah i mean usually
they're people try to keep them alive
and and then you know eventually the
skull ossifies
bone will try to meet bone that
condition starts basically from birth or
like within a couple months
uh and and it starts to separate because
again those bones were never fused
so
the they separate and separate and then
eventually the bone tries to grow
together
that isn't to say there is supposed to
be a predetermined size there kind of is
a predetermined size but it's based on
several factors it's based on partially
your brain partially a timing of
ossification
i mean maybe even if you had a normal
sized head but you delayed ossification
in the skull maybe your brain would grow
bigger i i don't think so there's
probably research into this but i think
it's multiple factors that then kind of
give us the average human brain size or
average human skull size yeah yeah
actually the
i was talking to the bone clones guys
about
because they actually have one of the
specimens is one of these
he was an adult he died in his 30s which
is super rare
usually you either have to treat it
right away
or you'll die and this guy somehow lived
to his 30s but they said that when they
got the skull it was almost paper thin
in some spots of course yeah and so they
had to be
it was really hard for them to make a
cast of it because you have to put it in
this plastery rubbery stuff
and they don't want to crush it of
course right
so it was uh
that is interesting so the skull i mean
it was it is
insanely huge
it's it's unbelievable this is a human
but it's it's
like like he was saying it's it actually
did cause problems for the skull it's
not a nice thick skull like you would
you would hope and that's one of the
reasons why these people have such a
difficult time surviving the condition
because they could they could get it or
they could get a
brain bruise i guess really easily
i mean i assume there's a lot more
problems than just having a thin skull i
mean having that much pressure on your
brain and not being good yeah i think
now it's it's early the early treatment
for it now is just a shunt to kind of
take out as much of the fluid as
possible i don't know what the more
permanent treatment is but it
i mean i'm a big fan fan oh it sounds
horrible but i'm super interested in
pathologies for this exact reason right
they help us understand what is normal
or why
we actually get the normal physiology
because
if you if all you have is normal skulls
you don't get these questions right you
don't get why
why does bone do this or why does bone
do that well that's it for this clip but
don't worry i post clips regularly and
every thursday
i post completely fresh content make
sure you're subscribed
liking and commenting is also welcome